[Applause]
[Music]
I was born in 1925
I carried out my youth where the end of the
war 14 18
then I knew the next one or
grandfather carried out at the beginning of the war 14
he led a charge and he  didn't come
out we had a painting at home
that depicted my grandfather and
for years years i ate
all my meals in front of this painting which
was very scary scary for a
6 year old
but alarmed him and may 28  40
he was captured by the donkeys and
he spent 54 avoid in germany
germany is still going to miss
quite a bit a certain age or people in
need of their father
we were refugees with friends and
here is mom but her is soft  in the
back of the trench with his friends there
in 1944 I had the possibility of
enlisting in the Belgian army because the
piron brigade
recruiting friends and I did our
training with the British army and
I became  radio operator on the
parts with hol shapes  lande we
stayed there since the signing of the end
of the war on May 8, 45
the war is over it has been over for
75 years and fortunately there is now
the European union thanks to that people
have gotten used to it
rather than fighting to separate and
the Europe that brings us together is the Europe
that softens morals in my
professional life I met
Germans never had a problem with that
our children and grandchildren and
great-grandchildren  not as one
of the facts historically but it was
exceptional
they did not help from the luck that they
have
he saves us it is in the
british cemetery and from the commonwealth in your c
in the belgian ardennes
and that is why  that i wanted to take
my grandson so that he knows how
to be the boy his age 75 years
ago fought here in belgium or
around so that we are there
now people tend to forget we talk
about  borders death by
futile things and greed  ssivity
me it always amazed me to see
that from these countries that our distant
there are boys of 19 years old the 20 years old
they are more six years old who are mauritius
for me how incredible it was
[Music]